When I was fighting for Nanny, who would be No. 1 in a domestic competition,
there was a description that he continued to take No. 1 as if he was pouring the dream of a talented junior and throwing it
.
Hey, I think he was the 2nd place in the competition the
other day. I'm glad I thought he was a very delicate person.
It was the summer of Brahms High 1, but that was my first friend in February.
I was overwhelmed by another talent like that.
Kurotoki Paiolino In
fact, the cherry blossoms that abandoned the gun
[Music]
Ametsuki Murata was never out of the world.
The size of the heart and emotions was bigger and richer than the person. It
seems that it is difficult to cut it stably.
Joy
also suffers from sorrow.
[Music]
I was so jealous of it that I was afraid of
pathology
[Music]
When I blew on my non-holding skin, I
felt like I was stabbed in
it  That person
wants to be naked and make this sound afterwards
[Music]